hey there friends so a couple weeks ago
I taught a video on how to do POI
flowers and specifically this variation
right here that is in together opposites
and I'm willing to bet that by now some
of you out there are kind of curious to
see what are the transitions you can use
to get in and out of this and I am going
to help you
out here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm going to show you what
transitions work with that together
opposites flowers so you can integrate
it more into your flow but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyrro
Tera light toys spinballs and Ultra poy
for helping make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-b buus friend of the channel Becca
beon thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission all right so lowkey as I'm
starting to record this uh I'm doing so
on Monday uh April 8th which means that
the eclipse is starting up as I am
recording this and as you can see I have
my incredibly Hightech and very very
Advanced Eclipse viewer with me the uh
challenge here is going to be to try try
and see if I can get this video shot
before the eclipse reaches totality so
let's see if we can make that happen so
I'm going to take you through a few
different options to be able to
transition in and out of this poy trick
depending upon whether your skill level
is beginner intermediate or Advanced and
I'm going to give you two options for
each level so let's dive in so just true
viw the trick in question we are doing
ins spin flowers two pedals in together
opposites that is butterfly so we've got
the pedals when our arms crossed and we
got the pedals out to the sides here so
first up let's take a look at some
beginner options so if you watch that
tutorial that I uploaded a couple weeks
ago you will already know that one of
the steps that I taught people was to
perform butterflies in the middle here
in order to get those middle petals in
now I think that's kind of boring so I
want to give you something that's got
just a little bit more spice to it and
that option would be a thread the needle
where we switch which hand is on top
every time we perform a beat with the
poy that way we do actually have a
dynamic shift every single time we
switch back and forth between these two
moves option number two you know I'm
always a fan for mixing up driving
Styles so one of those things that we
can do is as our po are going down
across the bottom we can actually take
that as a moment to switch into
performing pendulums again with our
hands in together opposites and we just
add a little bit of momentum into the
poy to get them all the way back into
being able to perform those together
opposite inpin flowers you with me so
far awesome let's check out some
intermediate options then all right so I
will fully confess that I love this
moment in the middle here where my arms
are over lapping and that's going to
turn out to be a theme for all of these
different uh skill levels here but one
of my favorite things to do with that
moment is to take it into a plane
breaking place and switch into cork
screws that is I can take that moment
where I have my hands overlapping and
the PO pointing to either side and all I
need to do then is pull my right hand
out and let the left hand follow it in
order to go into that cork screw to get
back all I have to do is wait for that
point where my hands are kind of
overlapping again and the right PO is
going off to the right to switch back
into those pedals so I go
in and I go out just like so and of
course I'd be remiss if I didn't talk
about the possibilities of transitioning
into other flowers from this one being
as how we're using horizontal pedals
probably the easiest option then is to
switch into doing split times same
direction flowers like so we can either
perform that when the hands are
overlapped like so in which case we get
kind of a cool reverse spiral wrap
effect to it or we could also do it when
the POI are out to the sides like so and
treat each of those side pedals as
though they're stall again we can do the
same thing coming back in order to get
back to those together opposites in spin
flowers pretty cool all righty then so
if you're following along great so far
then let's dive into the more advanced
stuff and uh this will be where I really
get to take off and have fun all right
so first and foremost has to be said
again this moment where our hands are
overlapping and more importantly the poy
are overlapping opens us up to do
something that I think looks really
really cool and really really really
requires you to have an incredible
amount of control over the momentum the
poy namely at that point where I have
them both overlap I can switch into an
isolation see how I did that so as I'm
coming around and I have my arms crossed
here and the POI crossed what happens is
I let the leftand poy continue on its
merry way but I treat the right hand poy
as though it's just on a stall and I
instantly switch my right hand back so
it winds up looking something like that
pretty nifty huh getting back is a
little bit more complicated you do want
to wait until your arms are overlapped
but once you get there hey I think it
looks pretty good don't you oh the
eclipse is starting physics man this
stuff is wild all right so for my final
pick I'm going to throw a bone to those
of you who like your throws namely we're
going to see what happens when we
perform ins spin throws from those
outside pedals all right so this one you
probably want to practice one hand at a
time you're going to want to try and
practice just getting in those in spin
throws tossing from one hand to the
other you want to make sure that you're
clearing your body going to either
shoulder here uh if you're not clearing
your body if it's coming down on your
Center Line it makes it more likely that
the PO you're going to Rin into each
other also you want to make sure that
when you do the release your hands and
po are in slightly different planes
you're using different Lanes here rather
than having them be right smack dab next
to to each other you've got one in front
of the other that way they have room to
clear each other when you make the throw
and in theory you get yourself all the
way around to make the toss and you have
a lovely catch waiting at the end all
right so let me show you a bunch of
these transitions in
[Music]
action
wo cool so I hope that gave you some
ideas and inspiration
if you're having a tough time figuring
out these transitions or you are
interested in more fully integrating
your flowers into your flow I can help
you out I'm teaching a live stream POI
dance class that centers around these
POI flowers that starts up on Tuesday
April 16th we're going to run that class
for four weeks and not only am I going
to be teaching you all of these
Transitions and more but we're also
going to learn a 30 second snippet of Po
choreography that you'll be able to
perform by the end of class come check
it out at crowdcast doio / drexfactor
poy did you get anything out of this
video please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe to help other people
find it and to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now uh thank you so much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission and for those of you out there
that are not currently subscribers if
you would like to help me out in making
more of these videos in the future you
can head on over and sign up at patreon
over at
patreon.com drexfactor poy and sign up
uh there you'll get access to a whole
host of awesome rewards and even better
than that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out that tutorial
that I did teaching you how to do po
flowers and only 30 minutes I will go
ahead and leave a link to that down in
the description as well as up on screen
thank you so much for watching make sure
to get out in flo day and I'll see you
with a new video real soon enjoy the
eclipse wherever you happen to be and uh
take care peace